si se va a someter a determinados
procedimientos como cirugía de pelvis
cadera o piernas puede evitar la
anestesia general y en lugar de ella
recibir anestesia peridural o raquídea
durante el procedimiento la anestesia
peridural y rachidia también se utilizan
con frecuencia durante el parto tanto la
anestesia peridural como la rachidia
consisten en inyectar el medicamento
cerca de la médula espinal esto hace que
el cuerpo se adormezca desde el pecho
hasta los pies entre las ventajas de la
anestesia peridural y rachidia se puede
mencionar la capacidad de permanecer
despierto durante la operación y la
prevención de riesgos asociados con la
anestesia general debido a que la
anestesia peridural y rachidia raras
veces ocasionan disminución de la
presión arterial y otros cambios que
pudieran requerir tratamiento inmediato
se le colocará una vía endovenosa para
que los líquidos o medicamentos puedan
administrarse rápidamente además estará
conectado a varios monitores para
controlar la presión arterial el pulso y
el contenido de oxígeno en la sangre
antes de recibir anestesia peridural o
rachidia el anestesista usará una
solución antiséptica
para limpiar el área de la espalda en
donde se le inyectará el medicamento
para disminuir el dolor del pinchazo es
posible que el anestesista coloque
anestesia local directamente sobre la
zona donde se aplicará la inyección
peridural o raquídea
la anestesia raquídea consiste en la
aplicación de una sola inyección dentro
del saco del líquido que rodea a la
médula espinal para llegar a este saco
de líquido el anestesista pasará una
aguja a través de la piel entre las
vértebras y finalmente a través de los
ligamentos de la duramadre que es la
membrana que protege a la médula espinal
la anestesia raquídea comienza a
trabajar casi inmediatamente después de
aplicarse la inyección con la anestesia
peridural la aguja no penetra la
duramadre y el medicamento se deposita
justo afuera del saco de líquido que
rodea a la médula espinal la anestesia
peridural se puede administrar en una
sola dosis o el anestesista puede dejar
un tubo pequeño y flexible o un catéter
colocado en el lugar en caso de que se
necesite más anestesia durante un
procedimiento que resultó más largo de
lo esperado la anestesia peridural tarda
aproximadamente 10 minutos en hacer
efecto después de la aplicación de la
anestesia espinal o de retirar el
catéter peridural se colocará un pequeño
vendaje sobre el área donde se insertó
la aguja